todo estaba en las manos del presidente
donald trump no puso su firma en el
proyecto de ley de estímulo y cerca de
14 millones de estadounidenses perdieron
los beneficios por desempleo por lo
menos por una semana
un acuerdo había sido logrado luego de
meses de negociaciones tortuosos entre
los demócratas y republicanos en el
congreso pero a inicios de esta semana
el mandatario se rehusó a firmar el
proyecto de ley diciendo que los 600
dólares de ayuda estipulados para los
individuos no eran suficientes
les le pido al congreso que enmiende
este proyecto de ley y aumente los
ridículamente bajos 600 dólares a 2000
el proyecto de ley que ahora planean
enviar a mi escritorio es muy diferente
de lo previsto es realmente una
desgracias
palabras que tomaron al congreso por
sorpresa chop no se opuso al acuerdo el
pasado lunes cuando fue sometido a
votación y de hecho eran los demócratas
los que habían insistido en que los
estadounidenses deberían recibir un
monto más alto de berna créanlo o no los
demócratas están de acuerdo con el
presidente 600 dólares no son
suficientes para los individuos que la
han pasado más durante los últimos siete
meses y no son suficientes para darle un
impulso a las necesidades de nuestra
economía
con su decisión trump puso millones de
dólares de ayuda económica en el limbo
incluyendo 286 mil millones para las
familias y los desempleados 284 mil
millones para los pequeños negocios y 70
mil millones para las vacunas y pruebas
de covite
también dentro del acuerdo estaba una
pausa en las órdenes de desalojos sin
ella millones de personas perderán sus
viviendas el proyecto de ley también
contempla 14 billones de dólares en
funcionamiento del gobierno lo que
significa que si no hay firma para
entonces la administración tendrá que
cerrar parcialmente a la medianoche del
lunes